[Music]
deaf singer Mandy Harvey left the judges
stunned on night one of the America's
Got Talent finale not only did she
perform another original song her
opening package tugged at the
heartstrings a weeping Mandy sharing the
painful story of losing her hearing I
thought that it was going to forget
every song that I'd ever heard all of my
memories I wasn't going to ever hear my
family saying I love you me about that
emotional opening package I mean how
could you
how'd you muster up the courage to even
perform after that it was so hard for us
to watch too you know it was very
powerful I I will I broke a little bit I
was I was really fighting holding back
tears at the very beginning so I had to
really shift my thought but it was very
difficult to sing I was I was very
internally emotional but trying to stay
very positive at the same time I got to
say that was a performance worthy of the
million dollar prize but I gotta ask do
you feel like you're already a winner
having been able to share your story
with the world my life is never going to
be the same and in in a beautiful way
and
it's just the fact that I showed up is a
huge victory have you thought about what
you would do with a million dollar prize
if you were to walk away with it
tomorrow night
oh absolutely there's a few things I
want to do I want to help create and
change how concerts are set up to make
them more integratable for people with
and without disabilities I want to put
instruments in the hands of people who
can't have them kids in hospitals to
make fully sterilized ukuleles or other
instruments that you know if they're
going through cancer treatments they can
actually hold on and do something with
regardless of if I win a million dollars
it would definitely help start but
regardless if if I win a million dollars
I'm gonna do it anyway
[Music]